[Musique]
bienvenue pour un nouveau numéro du v y
paie au golf de la bouillie à versailles
en compagnie d'une icône du décryptage
et du commentaire sportif gérard holtz
bonjour bonjour écoénergétiques / icon
ce que je me suis jamais vraiment
considéré vraiment comme comme une
vedette nique nique comme une icône
message est un message et un messager
entre le sport l'actualité et le grand
public
ça c'est ça c'est bien messager et puis
surtout le partage vous êtes aujourd'hui
à la retraite et et vous parrainez lives
in business club une association de
chefs d'entreprise on va voir les images
d'ailleurs du premier déjeuner et du
club vous étiez l'invité pourquoi
justement c'est pour le partage que vous
avez accepté de parrainer ce club j'ai
toujours aimé découvrir rencontrer
partager discuter
j'aime apprendre voilà et c'est vrai que
grâce au business club
là on rencontre des chefs d'entreprise
des responsables de discipline et de
niveau différent du commerce de
l'industrie des services et qu'ils me
racontent leur vie leur travail leur
leurs objectifs leur la façon dont ils
envisagent la vie et j'aime bien ça moi
j'aime bien j'aime bien apprendre j'ai
toujours cette envie pour ça que j'ai
voulu être journaliste c'est apprendre
pour ensuite pouvoir en parler or
justement avant que vos études de
journée vous avez fait du droit c'est
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous a lancé dans
le journalisme en fait c'est très très
simple j'ai un coup de foudre pour le
métier de journaliste je vais j'entends
je suis au lycée au lycée turgot à paris
j'entends une émission sur europe 1 où
il était possible d'être dans le public
pour écouter les journalistes faire leur
journal j'y vais et là à l'époque un
grand bonhomme qui savait jacques paoli
présentait le journal
et là en voyant des journalistes parler
de politique étrangère d'économie de
culture et de sport je me dise
exactement le métier que je veux faire
parce que on apprend les choses on les
assimile et puis ensuite on
où les explique au grand public voilà ce
que je peux faire un peu avec de
l'audace
je trouve le nom dans le journal le
monde un journaliste en bas de page
michèle castaing
je m'en souviens encore je trouve le
numéro du journal le monde
j'appelle je cherche à parler à michèle
castaing qui me répond et qui me dit
mais oui venez me voir un quart d'heure
c'est bon je vais vous expliquer ce que
c'est je connaissais pas j'ai et je
lisais pas le monde à l'époque je fais
un coup de cutter pour jusqu'au journal
le monde il me reçoit michel castaing
décédé depuis
il était à la rubrique éducation il m'a
dit deux choses 1 pour faire le centre
de formation des journalistes de il faut
faire les études supérieures et c'est
possible du droit c'est exactement ce
que j'ai fait j'ai écouté 100% ce que
m'a dit michèle castaing et puis les
choses ont marché une porte d'entrée
donc via la presse écrite puisque le
journal le monde c'est la presse écrite
et vous avez fait que finalement 40 ans
de carrière dans le service public
audiovisuel en 1972 alors ftf ce qui est
devenu après antenne 2 et aujourd'hui
france télévisions vous avez pris votre
retraite ans en 2016 est ce que ça vous
manque aujourd'hui pas du tout pas du
début du début du début du début non
parce que je me suis préparé un je me
suis préparé et 2 j'ai d'autres passions
et j'ai d'autres activités donc ça ne me
manque pas du tout 2
certaines personnes qui ne vous
connaissent pas ont pu penser que
j'étais accro à l'antenne au direct
c'est vrai que c'est très fort c'est de
l'adrénaline être sur le tour de france
avec avec
froome démarre
on m'a bardet vivre l'étape c'est très
très fort d'être sur le dakar en
hélicoptère avec les motards avec les
voitures etc
tout ça c'est des moments très très fort
mais ça faisait quand même deux ou trois
ans que je pensais un commencé à
réaliser des documentaires ou des films
de l'écrire des livres 3 jouer au
théâtre
4 faire du vélo faire du gorille et si
j'ai pas assez de non ça ne manque pas
la réponse est non il me manque parce
que finalement vous commentiez le sport
mais le sport c'est d'abord votre
passion et notamment via le cyclisme
alors nous sommes dans les yvelines
terre de vélo un vélodrome nationales de
villes étapes du tour de france l'an
dernier ou cette année rambouillet et
aussi l'accueil du paris nice
l'autre course de vélo en vous parcourez
aussi les routes des yvelines alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
comment ça se passe qu'est ce que vous
faites sur les routes il wiener je suis
limitrophes je suis 92 depuis pas mal de
temps mais c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois
que je sors de mon 92 c'est pour rentrer
dans 78 c'est pour rentrer dans les
yvelines
parce que c'est un sou c'est un cetain
ce sont des parcours extraordinaire
les petites routes boisées tranquille
joli il ya plein d'animaux parce que
j'ai déjà dit qu'à chaque fois c'est ma
récompense quand je vois un renard quand
dieu voit une biche quand je vois un
ebook ans durant un lapin pour moi c'est
une récompense d'une sortie ça a
commencé il ya pas mal d'années j'étais
j'habitais en face du parc des princes
dans le sein dans le déjà dans 92 dans
le 16e et dans le 92 et je partais sur
les routes alors soit soit vers
feucherolles saint nom la bretèche en
direction de ben par exemple soit on va
les tuer heureuse et il ya maintenant
c'est encore plus vrai parce que je me
suis rapproché d'abord j'ai vécu à
garches ensuite aujourd'hui je suis à
vaucresson je suis juste à la frontière
de la celle saint cloud ide 78 et tout
de suite le vélo m'emmène sur les routes
du 70
et c'est vrai qu'elle est parcours
extraordinaire c'est un plaisir je
traverse versailles et après je prends
ou à gauche ou à droite
il ya de toute façon c'est énormément de
plaisir et puis on vous a vu aussi sur
un vélocipède c'était en décembre 2017
on va voir les images dans le cadre
d'une reconstitution de la première
course cycliste entre paris et
versailles en 1867
alors en quoi l'histoire c'est aussi
important c'est peut-être l'une de vos
patients d'ailleurs en quoi c'est
important de connaître l'histoire pour
peut-être commenter l'actualité
notamment pour le sport j'adore revenir
systématiquement sur le passé sans
nostalgie mais pour en fait c'est tout
bête mais pour s'appuyer sur le
président pour mieux comprendre le
présent et lorsque des copains
collectionneurs m'ont appelé en disant
on reconstitue la première course entre
paris à versailles sur vélocipède j'ai
dit stop là j'habitais à rome à l'époque
n'est pas simple je suis arrivé jeudi
soir le vendredi je me suis entraîné
pour la première fois sur un vélocipède
avec une ronde qui mesure 1 mètre de
haut là quand la grande roue devant il
neigeait à croissy j'ai mon copain
collectionneurs je ne suis pas tombé et
j'ai participé on était une vingtaine et
c'est vrai que c'est un grand souvenir
et ça m'a donné l'idée de faire un jour
un documentaire sur l'histoire du vélo
parce que c'est quand même
extraordinaire de savoir que d'abord
c'est un français qui a une famille déjà
mis les michaud qui ont inventé le
vélocipède repris après par par les
anglais avec diminution de la roue avant
l'invention de la chaîne même mais
d'avoir vécu cette expérience là avec
accueil accueil à bachy qu'est le
spécialiste le japonais kel de
l'histoire du vélocipède d'avoir vécu
cette expérience
m'a enrichi de façon extraordinaire est
d'arriver à versailles en face du
château a accueilli par monsieur le
maire avec ses vélocipède en face de la
en face de ce moment d'histoire
c'était un grand moment elle a aussi un
moment de partage comme vous faisait
aussi sur le tour de france parce que
finalement vous êtes le journaliste qui
l'interviewait les champions le maillot
jaune à l'arrivée le vainqueur d'étape à
l'arrivée et mais aussi ses vous étiez
le journaliste qui aller au contact des
spectateurs parce que le tour de france
est aussi ça c'est le spectacle autour
du de la course le tour de france c'est
le tour de la france
en fait c'est l'événement qui est
continue d'être gratuit et qui parcourt
toutes les routes de france dans dans ce
qu'il ya de plus beau chez nous c'est
extraordinaire on a des paysages entre
montagne mer campagne toutes les
couleurs du mois de juillet le jaune le
vert les lacs le bord de la mer
c'est il y à un écrivain tue pas sûr que
ce soit blondin mais qui a dit le tour
de france c'est la france sur le pas de
sa porte et c'est exactement ça de vivre
ça chaque année renouvelée non seulement
la course mais même les petites routes
moi ça m'a fait découvrir la france
vraiment j'avais des destinations aux
favoris de la bretagne la vendée j'ai
pas mal de copains le béarn la provence
mais la grâce au tour de france j'ai
découvert par exemple les ardennes c'est
magnifique
l'ardèche l'ariège les trois là c'est
une merveille c'est une merveille le
tour de france c'est ça aussi mais alors
là aussi on peut découvrir des paysages
magnifiques c'était votre autre passion
c'est le sport automobile et notamment
le paris dakar
est ce que ces deux événements sont
comparables au tour de france et le
paris dakar je veux dire par là que
finalement on suit des champions on suit
le calvaire de que peuvent vivre
certains champions mais aussi on
rencontre des populations avec leur
manière de vivre alors une chose est
est comparable c'est les paysages parce
que c'est vrai que grâce au nouveau
système qu'on a mis sous un hélicoptère
pendant le tour de france par exemple on
re découvre les grands paysages français
les châteaux les vallées les montagnes
les lacs et c'est vrai aussi sa sueur
sur le dakar c'est vrai aussi que le
dakar aujourd'hui un petit côté tour de
france en argentine au chili au pérou il
aime tellement l'événement qui sont
maintenant des milliers des centaines de
milliers et même des millions sur le
bord des pistes pour voir passer les
événements donc tout ça c'est c'est
relativement comparables
l'ambiance du bivouac est aussi
comparable à celle de la caravane oui
dwi d'une certaine façon oui maintenant
le soir au bivouac sur le dakar il ya
des milliers de gens qui viennent
partager avec nous qu'ils viennent boire
un verre et saluer les concurrents un
peu comme ça se passe sur le tour de
france mais si on doit conclure votre
carrière parce que vous avez aussi
présentés stade 2 vous êtes un homme de
plateau aussi de présentation en plateau
mais aussi le terrain qu'est ce que vous
avez préféré est ce que c'était la
présentation en plateau où c'était
plutôt aller au terrain au contact de
des personnes tout mon capitaine
tout tout basiquement je me suis
toujours sentie comme reporter c'est à
dire d'aller sur le terrain d'aller au
contact partagés lundi mots-clés
partager découvrir pour en parler aux
autres et puis après il ya c'est vrai en
télévision il ya la possibilité d'être
commentateur ou d'être présentateur j'ai
eu la chance on m'a demandé de le faire
de pratiquer en gros toutes ces
disciplines
je n'ai jamais privilégié ni l'un ni
l'autre et en particulier par exemple
sur le dakar où je faisais les trois
choses je faisais le résumé de l'ex de
la course moto gt gt présentateur et on
puis je faisais les interviews sur le
terrain donc pour moi ça c'était l'idéal
de faire les trois choses en même temps
on arrive bientôt au terme de cette
émission si on doit faire un maître en
perspective et puis voir les prochains
défis que gérard holtz qu'elle est
sensible monter sur une scène en théâtre
en cerveau septembre en septembre 2000
19 parce que j'ai deux projets dont
canin qui va avec des discussions cette
semaine encore mon septième livre de la
collection chez gründ qui s'appelle sans
histoire de légende
ce sera sur le vélo voilà parcours est
encore les yvelines à bicyclette de plus
en plus j'ai un nouveau vélo il faut
vite que je le sorte maintenant que la
neige a disparu ggp il ya plein de
projets j'ai pu j'ai plein de projets je
n'arrête pas lorsque je vous propose
c'est de conclure votre émission avec
votre signature
on va le faire ensemble d'accord on va
regarder la caméra et on va dire qu'à
celle là voilà c'est la livre de son
bord merci gérard holtz d'avoir
participé à ce véhicule est un plaisir
[Musique]